hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today mention the
question from one of my readers Richard
who wrote in saying that he had
purchased one of my worksheet patches it
packages getting past survival and he's
trying to make a name for himself it all
things entrepreneurship and he's
wondering how what kind of advice I can
give him on making videos like I do
you've now become a wonderful
entrepreneurial source for me thank you
Richard so thanks for buying the
worksheets Richard hopefully you're
enjoying them and working your way
through them to answer your question
about how I do the videos I'm going to
kind of split that up into two two
components i guess for you the first is
talking about the equipment and at the
start making videos can be really scary
I know for me I i was a little bit
uncomfortable in front of the camera and
it took a while to get going it took me
lots of takes to make each video and it
was frustrating and a really slow
process now I just kind of read a
question and just start answering so it
takes a little bit of a muscle to work
an exercise to get better at it if
you're first starting out your equipment
I'm not a big believer in spending money
until I'm making money so I try to do
things on the cheap as much as possible
bootstrap so in my time but not my money
and find ways to get it started and so
my very first video was off of just my
little camera and use it off of a flip
and if you go back and youtube channel
you'll be able to go back and see how
help poor quality they were things were
shaking a little bit the lighting was
really brutal and then slowly slowly got
better and invested in better equipment
as I started making some money off of it
so you can go out and buy all the fancy
equipment if you want but the risk is
that maybe you won't love making videos
or maybe it's not going to be something
you stick with and in the end up with
all this equipment that you know you're
not going to use and you have to you
know take back or sell so i don't i
don't like spending money till I find a
way to make money off of it so I started
off just me with my flip camera you know
you know wobbly camera and terrible
lighting and slowly I invested more and
back into it now I use just a sony
camcorder
from costco that i picked up it's on a
tripod that I picked up at a camera
store and I use a microphone that
connects so you can see here I've got a
little bit of a microphone coming up
through my sweater here and it did that
because people were complaining that the
feedback the quality of the sound wasn't
fantastic coming from a flip camera and
so I just found the the highest-end
costco camera that had external
microphone jack like to plug into in
terms of the workflow I just save
questions that come to me from my
readers and i would put them on my phone
and then i save them for the week and
then I just kind of go through them and
once a week I I sit here at my house on
a Wednesday and fire up fire up the
camera get a cappuccino ready to go so I
have a little bit more energy and drink
it back and start answering questions
and so if you're just getting started
you may not have an audience yet to pull
from right now with the questions that
come in to me are from my readers or
Facebook fans or YouTube video Watchers
all over the place which is awesome but
if you don't have that audience yet you
can build it up and basically go out and
look for questions you could join
different forms or different Facebook
groups or LinkedIn groups and see what
kinds of questions people are asking and
say that you're going to make a video
response for them and so hopefully then
they'll you know watch it when you
actually do create it may be spread the
word a little bit about it but that
would be how i would get started if i
didn't already have an audience to be
able to pull questions from so hopefully
that helps good luck and getting the
video started it is a grueling and tough
process to get used to at the start I
always had to do it by myself in front
of the camera I felt when there are
other people around it was a little more
nerve-wracking a little harder to get
the message out and I've done a lot of
TV and interviews and that kind of stuff
but for whatever reason when when it's
just you and and there's like a person
watching instead of asking you a
question like on a media interview it's
a little more nerve-wracking at least
for me it was a little bit harder so it
took a while to build the muscle and
just practice and you may have to go do
a lot of takes you know I may have only
done one or two videos in a whole day
that I was happy with
I now look back on it and I think all
those are those are really that's a
really bad but you know I kept them up
there so you can go back and check it
out and now I just it's a lot easier to
go through just as you get more practice
with it and we've had I don't know about
400 videos or something like that that
I've created now and keep keep going
strong with so hope that helps good luck
to you when you do launch your first
video let me know I'm excited to see it
and I will definitely watch that'd be a
cool full circle moment for those are
you watching if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below makes
trying to do more videos for you and if
you have a question about this video or
a question about your own business I'd
love to try to answer it for you if you
want to leave it in comments section
below so thank you and I'll see you on
the next episode
you